Oil prices have been weak for all of
2020, in part because of the shale energy
revolution in America, but also in part
to slow global growth. It's a problem
we've had since late 2014. Since late
2016,
there was a mitigation strategy in place
by OPEC members, plus a few more key
producers like Russia and Mexico.What's
new is that the COVID-19 crisis
has disrupted Chinese economic activity,
and with it global supply chains and the
demand for transport fuel. What's also
new is that the 2016 strategy OPEC+
used to cut production has fallen apart.
So we've got way too much oil on the
market, which the Saudis are selling at a
discount. It's an oil flood. We're seeing
free-market movement, but it is
weaponized by state-owned oil. The Saudis
are trying to starve out shale
production and take market share from
Russia, while hoping the Chinese economy
will pick up soon and COVID-19 doesn't
put the global economy into recession.
The good news is we have plenty of oil.
The bad news is we need the global
economy, especially the Chinese economy,
to pick up demand.
Do you think the COVID-19 crisis and declining oil prices are
related? let us know in our poll. Also, let
us know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.